are you writing right now yeah for
another wilderness record the reason I
ask you know we're good
you did three something corporate albums
TV series you have three Jack's
Mannequin and now you've done three
wilderness records so I know it's so
funny cuz I've had like all these people
coming up to me on this on this tour
I've been like I heard you I heard
you're retiring right the short answer
is me without writing songs and
releasing music and traveling is half of
me so yeah this is what I do I have no
like plans to like stop you know stop
recording or not do another wilderness
record or what I will say is like I
definitely feel like I'm in a transition
not necessarily that the project that
I'm not gonna do is project or whatever
but I think because there are these few
records and I think that all three sort
of do they speak to each other and then
and they do create a sort of feeling of
at least at the moment a feeling of
completion and like okay what's next
it's putting me in a position where I
feel like I'm going home with this like
fresh outlook and like who knows what's
next I wouldn't say it's a anything for
anybody to be worried about
Andrew McMahon inviting eg to soundcheck
ahead of his upside-down flowers tour
[Music]
and sitting down backstage to talk about
his family and what's next with this
tour over this has been amazing it's
been more work than I've ever put in
yeah this is like two hours top to
bottom and and so it's like we're
usually I'm the guy who's like let's go
out tonight this tours been like I need
to go yeah they're like it will be
bittersweet like when we pack it up
because I think as tough as it's been in
that sense like the connection has been
really profound it's been cool to be
able to play so much new music and so
much of the catalogue in one spot and
seeing how all these songs interact and
how these stories kind of the past
informs the present I did notice punk
rock princess is on there and that's
like going way back yeah into the
catalogue
like I like doing Park Prince's acoustic
like a lot at work it has a from me it's
a little more emotionally connected that
way it's also just fun for the audience
who hasn't really gotten to see us play
some of those older songs that were like
very young and just kind of simple rock
kind of supercharged
moments you know it felt like a good
time to resurrect it and put it in the
cellars the course is obviously it's a
little bit campy but but uh I still sort
of connect to the the general sentiment
of songs like that you know well let's
talk about your real life punk rock
friends that's your wife and of course
your daughter
do they come on the road of you they do
yeah they do how is that been for them
she loves it I mean it's getting it's
getting harder you know when we started
it was like you know she was just a sort
of nebulous or that you would just roll
around and she'd sleep when you needed
her sleep etc you know now she's five
she loves being with her friends in it
so we just try we try not to go more
than two weeks is kind of the rule so
they've been out songs when they are
here that they request over do they have
favorites the show is early enough that
Cecilia can watch the first handful of
songs it's more or less demanded that I
play rainy girl
[Music]
anything with anything that references
her she's very pleased to have it for
sure
it's crazy to me that she is five now
how was your life changed really in the
past five years a balance and fatherhood
and artistry ins it's interesting I
think it was I was more nervous about
how it would impact the professional
side then I think it turned out I needed
to be in a weird way like if you think
about it Cecilia is the biggest song
that I've ever released I didn't realize
that becoming a father would actually
sort of light a fire to do my best work
you make your way home more often
because you you you want to be there and
yeah but I mean a lot has changed you
know I think I think they are a factor
in my process now and that became I
think such a beautiful part of the story
of upside down flowers was this idea of
waking up with my girls and doing
breakfast and doing a you know whatever
I had to do to help you know get get her
off to school and then sitting down and
working on music I'm a little more
grounded although I've had my you know
I've had I've had that fall away from
time to time as well but I just think
I'm more focused he's doing something
right upside down flowers has been a hit
with fans largely in part to the
personal and nostalgic fact
[Music]
there's one song on there teenage rock
stars that is kind of really gotten a
lot of people talking excited and very
nostalgic have you heard from any of
your former bandmates there what they
say yeah I mean it I made sure they were
the first to hear it I waited until the
video got put together
I look at that song it's like a total
package with the video like it that's
the presentation of it that I love and
so yeah I sent it out to the guys and
everybody was super cool you know and I
was a little nervous too to send it but
I also feel like it feels very honest to
me it doesn't feel like there's a lot of
judgment in that song I heard though
that it took you a long time to actually
write it well yes yes and no I mean I
had tried throughout the course of the
Jack's Mannequin years to write that
song multiple times you know not how
come I didn't work then I don't think I
had enough perspective you know I think
it always kind of felt a little
one-dimensional or something you know I
just don't think that I was able to sort
of really pull the lens back far enough
and go this is what it was
now Andrew says he's looking forward to
writing with other artists and doing
film and TV scoring work I mean a break
no I said no I think it'll all be I love
this usually good this is what am I
getting real I would I true through
though I wouldn't be surprised if
there's more music so I go to Disneyland
with my kids for her birthday the day
after this tour ends and then I'm in a
studio for two days as recording your
new stuff just writing and working on
this what is inspiring you right now I
feel like there's this misconception
that you have to be sad to write a good
song for a lot of amazing songwriters
like yourself yeah but I think that's
not true yeah I mean oh I'm a big fan of
like the mundane that explored the
nuance of of like a normal or simple
life you know what I mean it's
and it wasn't really about what like how
to blow your world up to to see what it
is to talk about that you know I've done
that already a million times you know I
think for me it's really more about
putting myself in the position to be
writing what do you thin the next five
ten years it's I mean I've had I've had
that that thought like no that's not how
it's gonna be and there was it there
have been a couple of points like the
between Jax and this project I I took
time and did some different things and I
think that's what would be next like I
don't I don't know that it'll be the the
same cycle it's really hard for me to
say you know like it I think in a dream
world I'd be able to sort of plant some
flags and other areas of this business
as far as like being a songwriter who
can contribute but I like you know I
look at guys like like a Randy Newman or
something you know it's like I think
there's something really remarkable
about about you music david foster or
whatever like these guys who can write
for themselves they can write for other
people and and i i'd like to see it move
that direction and then and then let the
touring fall where it falls from
you